>> Chris: AS AMERICANS EMBRACE
FOR THE MEDICAL AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE CORONAVIRUS, U.S.
OFFICIALS ARE TRYING TO
ENCOURAGE PREPAREDNESS WITHOUT
SETTING OFF A PANIC.
JOINING US NOW,
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI, DIRECTOR OF
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
ALLERGY AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES,
DOCTOR, WE’LL COME BACK TO "FOX
NEWS SUNDAY."
WHAT’S THE LATEST ON THE THREAT
OF THE CORONAVIRUS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
HERE?
THE >> Dr. Fauci: WERE OBVIOUS
THEY HAVING AN ACCELERATION OF
CASES NOW, IF YOU LOOK EVERY
DAY, WE HAVE SOMEWHERE AROUND
350, PROBABLY GOING TO BE CLOSE
TO 400 IF IT IS AN EYES AND
ALREADY THERE.
WE HAVE AT LEAST 18 DEATHS, THEY
KEEP COMING ON EVERY DAY THAT
GOES BY.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS WHAT IS
CALLED COMMUNITY SPREAD IN
CERTAIN REGIONS OF THE COUNTRY,
PARTICULARLY IN THE AREA OF
WASHINGTON STATE, SEATTLE.
>> Chris: SO ITALY JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT IT IS GOING TO
LOCK DOWN AN ENTIRE REGION OF
MORE THAN ITALY THAT INCLUDES
MILAN AND VENICE WITH A QUARTER
OF THE POPULATION, MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE, NO ONE IS GOING TO BE
ALLOWED EXCEPT UNDER EXTRA
ORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES TO GO IN
OR TO GO OUT.
THAT HAPPENED HERE?
>> Dr. Fauci: YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE TO BE REALISTIC.
I DON’T THINK IT WOULD BE ESTHER
KONY AND AS NOBODY IN A NOBODY
OUT.
BUT THERE WILL BE, IF WE
CONTINUE TO GET CASES LIKE THIS,
PARTICULARLY AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL, THERE WILL BE MITIGATION
WHERE WE HAVE TO DO ESSENTIALLY
SOCIAL DISTANCING, KEEP PEOPLE
OUT OF CROWDED PLACES, TAKE A
LOOK AT SERIOUSNESS, DO YOU
REALLY NEED TO TRAVEL?
THOSE KIND OF THINGS.
I THINK IT’S PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT AMONG THE MOST RAW
MARBLE.
THAT’S THE THING THAT THE CDC
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT ARE
GOING TO BE MAKING SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW PEOPLE
WHO HAVE UNDERLYING CONDITIONS,
THOSE ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE,
PARTICULARLY ELDERLY WITH
UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
HEART DISEASE, CHRONIC LUNG
DISEASE, DIABETES, RIGHT NOW,
NOT WEIGHT, BUT RIGHT NOW TO
SORT OF TAKE A LOOK AT THINGS
THAT ARE AT HIGH RISK.
CROWDED PLACES, GETTING ON
AIRPLANES, AND ABSOLUTELY, DON’T
GET ON A CRUISE SHIP.
>> Chris: I’M GOING TO PRESS
THIS QUESTION, THOUGH, OF ADA
LEE, COULD YOU SEE A SITUATION,
YOU KNOW, A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
SEATTLE, AND WHAT’S GOING ON
THERE, WHERE A CITY IS SHUT
DOWN, OR ESTATE, OR REGION IS
SHUTDOWN, AND HE BASICALLY JUST
SAY, IN THE CASE OF ITALY, UNTIL
APRIL 3RD, NOBODY IN A NOBODY
OUT.
>> Dr. Fauci: IT’S POSSIBLE.
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO ON REAL-TIME
BASIS, AND THAT’S THE REASON WE
EVALUATED EVERY SINGLE DAY.
YOU DON’T WANT TO ALARM PEOPLE,
BUT GIVEN THE SPREAD WE SEE,
ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
THAT’S THE REASON WHY, WE’VE GOT
TO BE PREPARED TO TAKE WHATEVER
ACTION IS APPROPRIATE TO CONTAIN
AND MITIGATE THE OUTBREAK.
>> Chris: OKAY, MEANWHILE, THE
CRUISE SHIP, THE GRAND PRINCESS,
THE LATEST CALL IS THAT IT HAS
3500 PEOPLE ON IT, THAT IT’S
GOING TO DOG, PERHAPS AS EARLY
AS TOMORROW AT A NONOCCUPIED
DOCK IN SAN FRANCISCO BAY,
PEOPLE ARE THEN GOING TO BE
TAKEN OFF THE SHIP, THEY’RE
GOING TO BE SENT TO QUARANTINES,
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE, THE OTHERS TO
A BASE IN GEORGIA, WOULD YOU
PREFER THAT WOULD YOU PREFER TO
SEE PEOPLE STAND THAT SHIP?
>> Dr. Fauci: , I RECOMMEND WE
SEE PEOPLE GET OFF, WE DON’T
ONLY SEE YOU AT THE DIAMOND
PRINCESS WHERE THE SHIP BECAME
ALMOST A HOT SPOT OF TRANSITION.
I WANT TO SEE THEM GETTING OFF,
AND BE A PART OF THE APPROPRIATE
QUARANTINE AND/OR CARE FOR THOSE
WERE SICK.
>> Chris: THERE HAS BEEN SOME
CONFUSION ABOUT THE RESPONSE IN
THIS COUNTRY TO THE DISEASE.
FIRST OF ALL, WHEN A VACCINE
WILL BECOME AVAILABLE, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> President Trump: I’VE HEARD
VARYING NUMBERS, MATTER OF
MONTHS, AND I’VE HEARD PRETTY
MUCH A YEAR WOULD BE AN OUTSIDE
NUMBER.
>> Reporter: WHAT IS IT GOING
TO BE DEPLOYABLE?
THAT’S GOING TO BE AT THE
EARLIEST A YEAR-A YEAR AND A
HALF AS FAST AS YOU GO.
>> Chris: REALISTIC, WHAT’S
THE EARLIEST VACCINE WOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR AMERICANS TO TAKE?
>> Dr. Fauci: PEOPLE NEED TO
APPRECIATE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN A VACCINE THAT YOU’VE
PROVEN MARKS, THAT’S GOING TO
TAKE BETWEEN A YEAR AND A YEAR
AND A HALF.
WHEN YOU CAN GET IT SCALED UP,
THAT THE REASON WE’VE MET WITH
THE PHARMACEUTICAL COUNTRIES,
BECAUSE ONCE YOU SHOT WORKS,
THEN HE GOT TO SCALE IT UP TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOSES.
WE’RE TALKING AT LEAST A YEAR TO
YEAR AND A HALF, AT LEAST, AT
BEST.
>> Chris: YOU SOUND LIKE YOU
THINK IT’S LONGER THAN THAT.
>> Dr. Fauci: CHRIS, THE TEST
WERE DOING RIGHT NOW, GETTING IT
TO PHASE ONE TRIAL IS THE
FASTEST WE’VE EVER DONE.
DON’T CONFUSE THAT WITH WHEN YOU
CAN PUT IT IN SOMEONE’S ARM AND
A DEPLOYABLE WAY.
SO I THINK THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO REALIZE THAT, FOR NOW, THE
ANSWER IS NOT GOING TO BE A
VACCINE, IF, IN FACT, WE GO INTO
A CYCLE, WHERE WE COME BACK NEXT
YEAR, THEN WE LIKELY WOULD HAVE
SOME OPPORTUNITY FOR A VACCINE.
>> Chris: THERE HAVE ALSO BEEN
CONTRADICTIONS ABOUT WHEN AND
HOW MANY PEOPLE CAN GET TESTED.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
>> President Trump: ANYBODY
THAT NEEDS A TEST GET THE TEST,
THEY ARE THERE, THEY HAVE THE
TEST.
THE TESTS ARE BEAUTIFUL.
ANYBODY THAT NEEDS A TEST GET
THE TEST.
>> WE DON’T HAVE ENOUGH TESTS,
TODAY, TO MEET WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE WILL BE THE DEMAND
GOING FORWARD.
>> Chris: CAN ANYBODY WHO
NEEDS A TEST GET A TEST NOW?
>> Dr. Fauci: THE FACT IS, THE
TESTS ARE OUT THERE, THERE WAS A
MISSTEP EARLY ON WITH REGARD TO
THE TESTS, A TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY, BUT RIGHT NOW, ABOUT
1.1 MILLION TESTS ARE OUT THERE,
NOW.
THEY WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL COME
ABOUT 640,000, ON THAT SAME
MONDAY, THEN AT LEAST
ANOTHER 4 MILLION, PARTICULARLY,
NOW THAT WE ARE ENGAGING THE
PRIVATE SECTOR.
NOW, WHEN YOU SAY THAT, THEY ARE
OUT THERE, IF YOU GO TO A
DOCTOR, IT IS UP TO THE DOCTOR
TO ORDER THE TEST, AND IF THAT
HAPPENS, A PERSON SHOULD HAVE A
TEST AVAILABLE.
BUT IT’S NO DOUBT, CHRIS, YOU
HAVE TO BE REALISTIC, EARLY ON,
THERE ARE SOME MISSTEPS THAT
DELAYED IT.
>> Chris: I WANT TO PICK UP ON
THAT, DOCTOR, AND THE QUESTION
OF TESTING, I WANT TO PUT SOME
NUMBERS ON THE SCREEN, AS OF
THURSDAY, THE CDC HAD TESTED
ONLY 1583 PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA,
ONLY 516 TESTS.
MEANWHILE, IN SOUTH KOREA, MORE
THAN 66,000 PEOPLE WERE TESTED
WITHIN A WEEK OF THE FIRST CASE
OF COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION, AND
OF A CANAL TESTED 10,000 PEOPLE
A DAY, WHY ARE WE SO FAR BEHIND?
>> Dr. Fauci: IT GETS BACK TO
WHAT I SAID IN THE BEGINNING,
THAT THE CDC MADE A TEST, THERE
IS A TECHNICAL GLITCH THERE, THE
CDC PROVIDES TEST FOR THE PUBLIC
HEALTH GROUPS IN THE STATE AND
LOCAL.
WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO DO, NOW,
WHICH WERE THE NUMBERS THAT I
MENTIONED TO YOU, IS TO GET THE
PRIVATE SECTOR INVOLVED, SO THAT
YOU COULD LITERALLY FLOODED WITH
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF TESTS.
THAT IS HAPPENING NOW, BUT IN
FACT, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
TO REALIZE, THAT IN THE
BEGINNING, THERE WAS A GLITCH,
AND WE NEED TO OVERCOME THAT,
NOW.
>> Chris: YOU SPOKE WITH
POLITICO RECENTLY, AND I WANT TO
PUT A PART OF WHAT YOU HAD TO
SAY.
YOU SAID, "YOU SHOULD NEVER
DESTROY YOUR OWN CREDIBILITY,
AND YOU DON’T WANT TO GO TO WAR
WITH THE PRESIDENT, BUT YOU’VE
GOT TO WALK THE FINE BALANCE OF
MAKING SURE YOU CONTINUE TO TELL
THE TRUTH."
YOU HAVE HAD TO CORRECT THE
PRESIDENT A FEW TIMES,
ESPECIALLY ON THE AVAILABILITY
AND THE SCHEDULE FOR VACCINES,
WHERE DO YOU PERSONALLY DRAW THE
LINE BETWEEN REASSURING PEOPLE,
BUT STAYING AWAY FROM THE SPIN?
>> Dr. Fauci: I DRIES BEST AS
POSSIBLE, I THINK I SUCCEED OVER
MANY YEARS, OF STAYING AWAY FROM
SPIN, AND JUST GIVE PEOPLE THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU NEED BASED
ON EVIDENCE AND HARD FACTS.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE EVIDENCE, YOU
GIVE IT AS IT IS.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE ALL THE
EVIDENCE, BECAUSE WE ARE IN A
DYNAMIC SITUATION, YOU USE YOUR
BEST JUDGMENT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS AND GUIDELINES,
BUT YOU MUST ALWAYS, ALWAYS BE
TRUTHFUL WITH THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
>> Chris: THERE IS A STORY
TODAY ON AP THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
OVERRULED THE CDC, WHICH WANTED
TO WARN ELDERLY PEOPLE, AND
PEOPLE AND IT PHYSICALLY FRAGILE
CONDITIONS NOT TO GET ON
COMMERCIAL AIRPLANES.
ONE, DO YOU KNOW WHETHER THAT’S
NOT, AND TWO, WHAT WOULD YOU
TELL A RELATIVE OF YOURS WHO WAS
IN EITHER THAT CLASS ELDERLY OR
PHYSICALLY FRAGILE, WOULD YOU
SAY STAFF AIRPLANES?
>> Dr. Fauci: HERE’S THE DEAL,
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT AWAY,
CHRIS, THAT NOBODY OVERRULED
ANYBODY ABOUT SAYING THIS.
LET ME SAY IT LOUD AND CLEAR
NOW.
THE CDC HAS A HEALTH ALERT AND
THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS MORE OF
A TRAVEL ALERT.
RIGHT NOW, I’M TELLING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, BASED ON
EVERYTHING THAT’S AGREED UPON IN
THE TASK FORCE, THAT IF YOU ARE
AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS AN
UNDERLYING CONDITION,
PARTICULARLY AN ELDERLY PERSON
WITH AN UNDERLYING CONDITION,
RIGHT NOW, NOT WEIGHT, YOU
SHOULD START TO DISTANCE
YOURSELF FROM THE RISK, CROWDS,
GETTING ON A PLANE, A LONG
PLANE TRIP, ABOVE ALL, DON’T GET
ON A CRUISE SHIP.
THAT IS A HEALTH ISSUE.
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS
SAYING FROM A LOGISTIC
STANDPOINT, DON’T GET ON A
CRUISE SHIP, BECAUSE YOU CAN
COME OUT, HAS A HAVE A PERSON ON
THERE THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN, YOU
FIND YOURSELF NOT BE ABLE TO GET
BACK IN QUARANTINE, NO ONE HAS T
US NOT TO SAY THAT, AND I’M
SAYING IT VERY CLEARLY NOW ON
YOUR SHOW.
>> Chris: FINALLY, I HAVE
NOTICED, YOU’VE BEEN ALL OVER
TELEVISION THE LAST FEW DAYS,
YOU HAVE A BIT OF A RASPY VOICE.
HAVE YOU TESTED YOURSELF OR HAD
YOURSELF TESTED FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS?
>> Dr. Fauci: NO, BECAUSE I
HAVE NOT BEEN AT RISK.
MY RASPY VOICE IS THE FACT THAT
I’M TALKING TOO MUCH ON TV
SHOWS.
>> Chris: KEEP DOING IT, YOU
ARE A VOICE OF SCIENCE AND
AUTHORITY, WHEN PEOPLE HEAR YOU,
THEY HAVE REASON TO THINK
THEY’RE GETTING THE STRAIGHT